welcome back to lockdown math today we
are going to be talking about Euler's
formula and just to give you a little
sense of where we're going to be ending
up with this lesson I'm gonna go ahead
and show you what we're aiming for at
the end which is a certain visualization
so I don't expect you to necessarily
understand this immediately but the
point is that this is something we're
going to walk towards what we're going
to analyze is an extension of the idea
of Exponential's in a way that works in
the complex plane and the illustration
that you're looking at is showing very
literally what the claim of Euler's
formula is because what I want you to
appreciate is what the actual statement
says rather than letting it be shrouded
in a certain mystery or a certain
question of what the conventions are now
needless to say this is kind of a
confusing thing we've got this spiral of
vectors and if it's not entirely clear
don't worry about it
I just want to give you a little sense
of where we're going to be going with
this but before any of that let's take a
step back and remember where were we
okay back in the end of the last lesson
when we were talking about complex
members one of the key types of complex
numbers that we were looking at were
those that existed on the unit circle so
here I have a little complex plane drawn
we've got the real number line with the
points 1 and negative 1 indicated we've
got the imaginary number line I being
the square root of negative 1 and if you
remember one of the main points that we
emphasized last time is that when you
have a number who's sitting one unit
away from the origin at some angle theta
multiplying by this number has the
effect of rotating things by that angle
this is incredibly important throughout
physics throughout electrical
engineering all throughout math you see
these numbers everywhere they describe
wave mechanics they're very important
for polynomials it's really hard to
overstate how important numbers that sit
on this unit circle are now one way that
you could write them is with the real
and imaginary parts and based on lecture
two if we know our trigonometry the x
coordinate is going to be the cosine of
that angle and the y coordinate which is
the imaginary part is going to be I
times the sine of that angle okay so you
might think all throughout physics all
throughout electrical engineering you
see the expression cosine of theta plus
I sine of theta
in fact what you often see is another
form of this almost always you see this
written down as e to the power I times
theta and this relationship is what's
known as Euler's formula okay now he is
a special constant of nature and I
always remember in high school it was
never crystal clear to me exactly what
it was it was something that was just
kind of handed down okay it's 2.71828 on
and on and we were just taking you know
we were to take this as a an analogue of
Pi it's an irrational number that
evidently the universe side finds
significant I had one calculus teacher
who would tell us it was the Andrew
Jackson number because the president
Andrew Jackson served two terms he was
the seventh president and he was elected
in 1828 so there you go
I don't know if Andrew Jackson
appreciated this relationship that you
had to Euler but it always helped me
remember that number now just a gauge
sentiment because I'm not entirely sure
where the audience is I want to know
what your current relationship with this
particular formula is so we're going to
do a poll to start and this poll is
mostly going to be helpful to me so
pulling up some of the warm-up questions
that we had we're evidently most of you
if you were to choose one of Euler's
formulas would have gone with the one
that we're talking about today which is
great you know appropriate given where
we want to head as a poll that's
actually going to be helpful to me let
me ask you which of the following best
describes your relationship with the
formula e to the power I theta equals
cosine of theta plus I times the sine of
theta okay and the options here are that
you've never seen it before
totally understandable that you've seen
it but you're confused by it that you
still don't understand it but you've
grown used to it or that you understand
it well so as you can see answers are
rolling in please participate this is
going to be way fun if more of you
participate you can go to three b-1b
deco slash live link is also in the
description that four would do to the
place where you can answer this poll and
why all the answers are rolling in I
just want to remind us of a more famous
variant of this expression that you
often see which is basically what
happens when you plug in PI and so if we
say e to the I times
pi we're now we're thinking of pi as an
angle it's a it's a number of radians a
distance around the unit circle you
would plug in cosine of pi plus I times
the sine of pi okay and the way to think
about that is to look at the unit circle
and ask what if you walked around until
you'd walked a total distance of pi
you know if it's a lake with the radius
1 and you walk around the boundary until
you've got a distance of pi kind of by
the definition of what pi is that takes
you halfway around the circle so the X
component cosine is going to be negative
1 and then the Y component sine is
actually 0 so there's no imaginary part
it's just negative 1 and this gets us
you know what might be the most
celebrity equation in all of math e to
the I times pi is equal to negative 1 ok
but it's baffling genuinely baffling
because you've got this idea of raising
a constant which is a little wishy-washy
to start with what is e but you're
raising it to an imaginary power and if
you don't understand what that means
you're in good company I think very few
people in the world actually do now
turning back to our poll where we've got
a good number of responses and a pretty
good spread too
I'm genuinely curious to know who am I
talking to right now okay cuz it looks
like we have a pretty even distribution
among all camps all right so the number
one most common answer is C which is
those who still don't understand it but
they've grown used to it this I'm gonna
guess includes people like math majors
or engineering majors or people who have
gone into a technical field where it
comes up a lot so you have to grow used
to it this is also revealing the fact
that even though these lectures are
targeted at high school students that
this channel has a certain base
demographic to start with so sometimes
those sitting in the audience it's more
like adults who have walk in it walked
in and are sitting in the back of the
class very happy to see that D I
understand it well is a second most
common answer I'm curious
among those who answered e if by the end
of the lecture they would say that what
they understood about this is the same
as what I'm going to teach because for
example I would make the claim that this
formula actually has nothing to
do with the number II okay that the
number II doesn't actually play a role
in what this formula is computationally
saying and I'd be curious if those who
claim that they understand it well would
agree with that statement after that we
have those who've seen it but are
confused by it and at the very end is
the actual target demographic of those
who've never seen it before I don't know
if that's it's fair to call that the
target demographic because I think
sometimes you see it in a non
circumstance here there but definitely
those who answered a or B you're my
people you're the ones that I want to
talk to about this okay but let's say
you see this can you see this weird
formula e to the PI I or the
generalization e to the I times some
angle I think the healthy reaction to
have to this okay if you're just seeing
this for the first time the healthy
question to ask is w.t.f
okay what is the function at play and
how is it defined okay what's the
function because in this case the
function is e to the X and we're
plugging in certain imaginary inputs and
I think a lot of people think that that
refers to taking a number E and
multiplying by itself some number of
times and that X describes how often
you're multiplying by itself and that
yeah there's some notion of extending
that to things like 1/2 or negative 1 or
any kind of real number but that it's
based in this idea of repeated
multiplication now the thing that makes
this equation misleading is that that's
not the function that is not what each
of the X is referring to let's emphasize
that very heavily this is not what e to
the X means this is not its convention
instead what has emerged in math is that
we use e to the X to be a shorthand for
another function a function which I'm
going to give the name X this is how you
often see it in literature and it's
defined to be a certain polynomial it's
1 plus X plus x squared divided by 2
plus X cubed divided by 6 plus X
to the power 4 divided by 24 and in fact
it's not a polynomial it's an infinite
polynomial we add infinitely many terms
each of which look like X to the N
divided by n factorial the proper term
for this is a series in practice if
you're actually computing this because
that denominator grows so quickly you
can chop off the series pretty early to
get an approximate value for what this
actually is now right away we can see
that this is going to work for lots of
kinds of X that we could plug in
anything where we know how to raise X to
a power just a whole number power
multiply it by itself and where we know
how to divide by a factorial and add
those together we can come up with a
nice meaning for what this X function
means but Before we jump into things
like complex numbers and throwing that
in I think it would be very unsatisfying
to do that if we didn't first draw the
connection to the number E and the idea
of repeated multiplication because on
the surface this infinite polynomial
seems very different from the idea of
some special constant of nature E and
raising it to a power so let's build up
a little familiarity we're going to take
you know a couple minutes to do this and
it's very it's a very healthy exercise I
think to become friends with this
function by starting to plug in a couple
different values one of the first you
might plug in is the number one so that
way we get one and then X is 1 so that's
one x squared is still 1 so that's one
half and then one-sixth and then one
twenty-fourth
and in general we're adding 1 divided by
n factorial in math we say that this is
a series that converges in the sense
that as we add more and more terms it
approaches a certain value and it gets
closer and closer to some specific value
and that value ends up being around
2.71828 the Andrew Jackson number but at
this point just think of it as it was
going to be something X but one was
going to be something this is what X but
one happens to be at the moment there
isn't necessarily anything special about
that but let's say you wanted to plug in
other values ok just to get a little
practice with what
that would look like if I wanted Expo -
it would look like one plus two plus two
squared over two plus two cubed over six
and in principle if you were on a desert
island and you just needed to compute
Expo - you could work this all out by
hand if you were comfortable with long
division but of course we live in the
modern world we have computers we have
programming so I think to make this
especially concrete let's go ahead and
actually implement this function so that
we can calculate a couple values and so
that it's not a black box it's not just
a calculator that's been handed to us we
implement it so we know exactly what
it's doing so for that let's go ahead
and pull up a little Python this is
desmos we might look at that a little
bit later
right now let's be a little bit more
programmatic let's pull up some Python
let's import some math because that's a
sign you're always going to have some
fun then I'm going to define the X
function that's going to take in some
number X and what I want is to return
something that looks like 1 plus X plus
x squared over 2 where in Python this
double what do you call it an asterisk
this double asterisk sign is how we do
exponentiation and then X cubed over 6
and we kind of want to add that up a
whole bunch of course instead of typing
all that out we can use a little special
syntax where I'm going to say I want you
to return a sum of a bunch of terms each
term is going to look like raising X to
some power and it knows what X is
because that's what was handed to it X
to some power divided by the factorial
factorial of N and that's built into
this math package that we imported and
I'm just going to do this for values of
n that start at 0 0 factorial is defined
to be 1 if you're curious we could talk
all about factorials of weird values at
a later date but that's all you need to
know here and I'm just going to have it
range up to 100 because a hundred
factorial is going to be huge so that's
going to be plenty big enough for a
denominator to be small enough that
those later terms don't contribute a lot
okay so even if you don't know Python I
hope that this is a reasonably clear way
to turn
math into something that our computer
can chew on and crunch through the
numbers so that we don't have to so for
example if we type X above 1 we get the
Andrew Jackson number 2.71828 on and on
and I could type in expo 2 and it looks
like that's around seven point three
eight nine so maybe we even write that
in our notes we go over here and say
interesting X book two was about seven
point three eight nine okay and if you
spend a long time just kind of playing
around with this okay I think it's not
obvious that you might find this but if
you were just plugging in a couple
values X above three X before one
important fact you might stumble across
is that if I add two numbers in the
input okay so in this case they get 1096
when I plug in seven which is three
times three plus four that actually ends
up being the same as if I plug in X but
three times x before okay so adding the
input corresponds to multiplying in the
output and three and four weren't
special here I could have done you know
five point five and three point two and
that would have gotten me some value and
if instead I had added those together
okay it gets the same value that is not
at all obvious okay so I think that
would be a genuine discovery to have
with respect to this function with this
polynomial if that was something that
you found and it's it's important enough
that I want to write it down X of a plus
B is actually the same thing as X of a
times X of B
now if you just look at the polynomial
this is not clear okay this is not
something that like you look at it and
say oh yes of course it couldn't have
been any other way at the end of today's
lesson though I'm gonna give you guys
some homework and yes homework will make
you learn better and what we're going to
do is go through a couple problems that
are gonna have you show that this fact
is true that simply from the polynomial
and the fact that it includes these
factorial terms excuse me that's going
to be enough to show this very special
property now why am i calling it a very
special property well I want to ask you
a certain question that will hopefully
hopefully make this clear and it really
is important that you think this through
yourself because I think if we if I just
kind of tell you the implications here
it's not going to sink in to the same
extent as if you really noodle with it
yourself so I'm going to pull up another
question and I'm going to give you some
time to think on this one what the
question asks us is to suppose that we
have some function f of X that has this
special property we're adding two
numbers in the input F of a plus B gives
the same result as multiplying in the
output F of a times F of B and that this
is true for any real number a and B okay
suppose you have some function that
satisfies this property who cares how
its defined whether it's through this
polynomial through other means which of
the following is true one of the options
is that F of 5 is equal to F of 1 raised
to the power 5 another is that F of 1/2
is equal to the square root of F of 1
and the other is F of negative 1 equals
1 divided by F of 1 now very important
I'm not asking does there exist some
function f where these 3 things will be
true I'm asking which of these
necessarily has to be true only from
that property so you shouldn't be able
to contrive some sort of adversarial
function that doesn't satisfy it ok and
then you have various options for which
collection of these three things is true
I'm going to give you some time to think
about this because I really do think
it's important so I'm going to turn up
our pause and ponder music to get us in
the mood
and take a desperately-needed drink of
water
you
while you're noodling on that I'm gonna
go ahead and take a question from the
audience where it looks like surfed asks
what do you think is more interesting to
someone who is a newcomer to higher
level math special case theorems like e
to the I PI or more general cases like e
to the IX oh that is such a great
question by the way anyone who wants to
ask questions go to Twitter and just use
the hashtag lockdown math those will be
forwarded to me I think the best way to
learn is to have specific examples and
really let yourself understand the
patterns represented by those specific
examples and then generalize them for
the specific one that you have here I
think if you just if you just see e to
the I pi that doesn't really count as a
good specific example that explains the
the generality it's more that you're
plugging in one particular number into a
formula so in this case e to the i-x
as you'll see it has everything to do
with circular motion and between this
lecture and the next one we're going to
talk about why that relation might be
there so the form of having specific
examples that aids your understanding
wouldn't be you know a number like e to
the I pi it would be building a
relationship with circular motions in
other circumstances like studying
physics where you have a tetherball
with some kind of centripetal force and
it's orbiting or like orbital mechanics
anything where you're you're really
understanding the nature of circular
motion that actually prepares you for
understanding e to the i-x as a
generality a little bit better so with
all of that answers are still rolling in
and I don't want you to feel rushed so
I'm going to give a little bit more time
here actually because we remember you
need to really be sure that if you're
saying that something like 2 or 3 or 1
is included in your answer that any
function with this special property
necessarily follows that ok
oh let's let's see if we can grade it
when the on the top answer is the year
right it's a 2017 that's a little bit in
the past 2013 we're losing the top
answer interesting people are changing
their mind it's like we're going back in
time so it looks like a couple people
are oh now we're in the future 2023 yeah
so we're actually seeing people think
about it and thinking hang on you know
is it the case that option 3 here is
necessarily true and they're really
being critical about that so that's a
good sign if you want to keep thinking
about it please do but for the sake of
continuing with the lesson I'm going to
go ahead and lock things in here and see
how people ended up answering so it
looks like 20-30 of you the decade in
the future believed that all three of
these are necessarily true second most
common answer was B they only believed
that the first one is true and then
after that people who either included
number two or number three and the
correct answer is that all of them are
and it's very interesting to walk
through why I do think it's very
elucidating so let's let's go ahead and
do this the first one which it seems
like a majority of you believe is that
if we plug in something like five to a
function with this special property that
it'll be the same as taking F of one
raised to the fifth
now the reason is that we could also
write five as one plus one plus one plus
one plus one and this property of
addition in the input becoming
multiplication in the output means
that's the same thing as writing X both
one multiplied by itself five times okay
it lets you rewrite the whole thing in
terms of X both one which I'm going to
say five times this is the same as
taking X both 1 raised to the power 5
and here when I'm writing Exponential's
anytime you see a natural number a whole
number it can literally mean multiplying
by itself that number of times that's
not the same as the fact that e to the X
is a shorthand for this crazy polynomial
so that can sometimes get a little
confusing the exponent
playing two different roles and we might
give X both one a special name a
shorthand let's just call it e for short
that's not why we call this number e by
the way it it's also not because this is
what Euler's name starts with it's just
because whenever Euler was using this
the first time in a particular book he
was partial to vowels and the vowel a
had already been used
so he was just his arbitrary letter okay
so simply by virtue of this property we
can see that expo five has to be written
in terms of X both one well a little bit
trickier was the question about plugging
in one half okay and the key to solving
this it's a little bit tricky is to
think about what happens when we
multiply that by itself X but 1/2 times
X but 1/2 because of this property has
to satisfy or I should say has to equal
X both 1/2 plus X but 1/2 which is of
course X both 1 which let's say we're
using the shorthand and we call it e so
what does that mean X but 1/2 has to be
a number such that multiplying it by
itself equals e well that's what we mean
when we write square roots okay and the
last one was talking about negative
inputs so just as an example if we
inputted something like negative 1 so
the key here is to ask about multiplying
it by the value when you plug in 1 by
this rule that addition in the input
turns into multiplication in the output
that has to be the same as X of 0 now
what is expo zero oh you know what I'm
realizing hmm I think I might have
actually made the enter the wrong answer
there because in our case in our case
Expo zero actually does come out to be
the number one okay so if we plug in
zero for X then all of these you add
them together the only term that matters
is one so X book negative 1 times X plus
1 is equal to X plus 0 which is 1 so
this is true in the case of X I
I can't actually think to myself right
now if that's necessarily true you know
if we look if we look at our question
we're saying all we know about F is that
F of a plus B is f of a times F of B if
that necessarily implies that F of zero
is going to be one and I I don't think
it does I think we could construct a
function yeah because we could just
scale e to the X by some other amount
okay yeah so actually what's graded here
is is not entirely correct the correct
answer would be only one and two
I think someone correct me on Twitter if
I if I'm wrong about that
but very interesting so if we go back to
our paper let's see in the case of X the
this this value at 0 would be 1 what
does that imply well if we call X both
1/e that means we're asking what is the
number which when you multiply by e
equals 1 and it would be 1 divided by e
but yeah and for the general case but we
need the added condition that when you
plug in 0 you do get one now the point
of all of this right the reason that I'm
saying this is to emphasize why it's
reasonable that we use the shorthand
that when we say X both X for real
numbers X Y it would be very reasonable
to write this as e to the power x
because basically this special property
means that because you can use the
number 1 to access pretty much all the
real numbers by adding it to itself or
dividing as needed or negating and then
if you have certain continuity
restrictions that will let you extend
from rational numbers to all the reals
but that's a technical point you don't
need to you don't need to fuss over for
what we're doing right now
it lets you basically express everything
that this polynomial can output in terms
of what it outputs at the number 1 so
you might read e to the X as just or
whatever this polynomial is at the input
1 we can start exponentiating in terms
of that so that's the connection right
we could we could if we want to define
the number e to simply be where is this
polynomial at the number 1 and then all
of this would follow but I really want
to emphasize that only makes sense for
real numbers because as soon as we start
introducing things like complex numbers
you can't just add
to itself or subtract and divide and get
the number I and at math you often do
even crazier things where you plug in
things like matrices into this
polynomial which seems weird but you
know you can take a matrix and square it
you can divide it by two you can add all
of those together and that's actually a
very useful thing it's very useful for a
field called differential equations
which in turn is useful for physics in
quantum mechanics you often plug in
these things called operators which are
kind of like the mature older brother of
matrices and all of that looks totally
nonsensical if we're talking about a
constant raised to some kind of power
but what you have to understand is that
it's being plugged into this polynomial
okay so I understand why we have the
convention of writing this as e to the X
it makes sense for real numbers but I
think that's actually a bad convention
as soon as we start extending it and I
think that causes a lot of undo
confusion so with all of that said let's
finally have some fun and plug in some
complex values okay and before we do
that just as kind of a warm-up I want to
make sure that we're comfortable with
powers of I because that's what's going
to be important here yeah so let's pull
up our quiz and let's go ahead and ask
one more question and then I'll take a
question from the audience too while you
guys think about this remember that I is
defined to be a value that satisfies I
squared equals negative one okay it's
not it's defined for which values of n
does I to the power n equal negative I
okay so the spirit of this question is
to have people thinking deeply about
powers of I and I kind of I wanted it to
be a question that's not totally obvious
so one that you do have to put a little
mental energy into so let's go ahead and
take a question from the audience while
I take a drink of water
[Music]
f of X equals zero doesn't work with F
of negative 1 equals 1 over F of 1 yeah
f of X equals zero oh interesting yeah
okay so so they're saying that if f of X
ever outputs zero actually I'm not
entirely sure what say I'm saying f of X
equals zero doesn't work with F of
negative 1 equals 1 over F of 1 so I
guess that fact that F of negative 1 is
1 over F of 1 doesn't imply that the
output will ever be 0 so I could ask for
some clarification but I think that
might be giving at the general point of
the mistake of the question which was to
assume to extend the idea of X a little
bit too much where the fact that expose
0 equals 1 gives us this other property
and then Crispin Simmons says 3 is
included because f of X plus 0 oh ok
yeah ok great
great yeah someone thought this through
a little bit more deeply than I can
while live and on camera and under some
pressure f of X plus 0 is the same as f
of X times F of 0 which implies f of X
equals 1 awesome crispin you saved me he
saved me on this one that's a beautiful
way of thinking about it yeah all of
these these questions where you have
like a property of a function and you're
supposed to deduce facts they can be
very subtle and so in this case okay the
question was graded correctly the
property simply that addition in the
input becomes multiplication in the
output is enough to imply F of 0 equals
1 which in turn locks in the value for F
of negative 1 oh it's so pleasing one
little property can just lock in basic
not the whole real number line because
it didn't assume continuity but it locks
in pretty much any value you want
awesome excellent questions I love live
stuff even if I make errors it does feel
a little more interactive than the usual
videos so let's see how we're doing on
the quiz looks like we've still got some
answers rolling in we're trying to
understand which powers of I are equal
to negative I and the options include
multiples of 3 or multiples of 3 as long
as they're positive
or integers one below a multiple of four
or those where you're restricted to them
just being positive and I'm going to go
ahead and grade this question and as
always if you feel like you weren't done
by the time I'm locking it in know that
that's just for the sake of letting the
lesson progress forward if you wanted to
pause and think about it further
yourself especially if you're watching
this later that would be that would be
totally in the spirit of these lessons
okay so the majority or the plurality I
guess of you answered that it's all
integers one below a multiple of four
which is correct and the second most
common answer was basically the same but
restricted to positives great so let's
think through what powers of I actually
look like because this is going to be
the only thing we really need to plug in
complex values into this X function and
the way this can work if I pull out my
infinite supply of unit circles is to
remember that multiplication in the
complex plane includes a rotation
component and because I has a magnitude
of one there's only rotation so
multiplying by I has the effect of
rotating 90 degrees if you multiply by I
twice okay I squared you end up 180
degrees around reassuring it's supposed
to have a square of negative one and
this geometry lines up with that fact if
we multiply by itself three times to get
I cubed it ends up being a vector
pointing straight down multiplying by
itself a fourth time 90 degrees takes us
back to one so I to the fourth is 1 and
then after that they all start repeating
so basically all you need to know is
where's that exponent with respect to
powers of 4 if it's a power of 4 you're
at 1 if it's 1 above a power 4 you're at
I now the the trickiness of the question
was to also include the nuance of
whether this is only for positive powers
or negative powers but what a negative
power means if we write something like I
to the negative 1 that's defined to be 1
over I the number such that when you
multiply by it you get 1 and you can see
that that's actually the same as I cubed
this is the same as I cubed because
that's a number where when we multiply
it by I we get one negative one that's
also one below a multiple of four and in
general anything that's one below all
the negative multiples of four will also
satisfy this property all right so it's
a little tricky question but it's just
because I wanted you to think deeply
about this idea that powers of I of
whole numbers just have us ticking
forward by 90 degrees and finally we can
have our fun okay we can take our crazy
X X function and we could plug it into
Python if we wanted to and see how
things play there but first let me go
ahead and visualize it for you so I'm
going to let's see that circle is
already suggestively drawn but I don't
want that to be there I just want you to
think about this polynomial where I'm
gonna plug in I scaled by some kind of
constant which very suggestively I'm
going to give the name theta and then
what that means is taking 1 plus I times
theta plus I theta squared over 2 on and
on and just as an example let's crank
theta on up until it equals 1 and let's
try to think pretty deeply about what
this actually means computationally the
first term is 1 which we might draw with
this green vector on the bottom pointed
one unit to the right the next term is
going to be I times 1 so just I it's
pointed straight up with magnitude 1 now
think about what the next term is it's
going to be I squared or I theta squared
but theta is 1 so it's I squared which
is negative 1 over 2 so that's why this
next vector is pointed to the left and
it has length 1/2 okay then after that I
cubed is pointed straight down and we
divide it by 6 so now we just have an
itty-bitty vector that is of magnitude
1/6 and then they just get smaller from
there the next one is pointed to the
right but it has magnitude 1 over 24 and
they just shrink a whole bunch and so we
get something it's clear that this is a
computation that makes sense to do it's
not clear how we we know where it ends
up that feels like it's we're going to
require real math to have some kind of
theory behind it we could be
computational and pull up Python and
remember that it actually has built-in
support for complex numbers if
write something like complex of to three
it gives me a complex number with real
part two and imaginary part three and
what's cool is it it already knows the
rules for multiplication so I could
multiply this by other things it knows
how to take their product very cool now
given that our definition of this
exponential function if you'll remember
was only ever in terms of raising
something to a power and scaling it by a
factorial and then adding all those
terms up well it should make sense to
plug in something like complex zero one
which is how we write I in Python and
see what it pops out and indeed it
crunches through the numbers and it gets
for us something whose real part is
evidently around point five four who
knew and whose imaginary part is around
point eight four and in terms of our
visual you know that checks out it looks
like the real part is a little above 0.5
so point five five four I believe that
and the imaginary part is it claimed
what point eight four yeah that seems
about right
so at this point we can actually think
what is the claim of Euler's formula
okay what is it telling us about the
behavior here and my hope is that
Whitley's formula might have started off
mysterious but mysterious in a bad way
okay because when you initially see this
expression e to the I theta is equal to
cosine theta plus I sine theta telling
you that oh I guess imaginary exponents
get us on the unit circle it doesn't
leave you wondering about a real pattern
it leaves you wondering what the
convention is right it leaves you
wondering WTF
however right now what we can see is
what this is saying is if I plug in I
times theta evidently that's the same as
walking around a unit circle now that
feels very substantive there's a lot of
content to be had in that expression
because if we go to our visual what it's
telling us is that if I if I crank up
this value of theta the place that this
sum of vectors converges always sits on
a circle that's one of radius one that's
not obvious if you just look at this
expression and you think through what
it's saying very literally that is
definitely not something that just pops
right out of it but it becomes a lot
more beautiful in my opinion because
you're no longer asking questions of
convention you're asking questions of
the universe of actual patterns so just
to take the most famous input that there
is plugging in PI around 3.14 let's
think about what this is actually saying
it's saying okay the first term is 1 so
we've got our vector pointed 1 unit to
the right the next term is I times pi
okay so that's gonna be a vector that's
pointed up because of the I with the
length of pie around 3.14 which it looks
like it is the next one is going to be I
squared times pi squared over 2 so that
I squared means that it's negative okay
it's pointing to the left and I guess
the magnitude is pi squared over 2 we
could do a quick gut check if we wanted
and just ask ourselves you know what is
what is pi squared it's around 9.8 same
as the gravity on earth in terms of
meters per second squared which is
always fun and dividing that by 2
it looks like it's 4.9 3 ok does that
check out yeah I buy it that the the
length of this vector is just less than
5 so 4 point 9 3 and then the next one
because of the I cubed is pointed down
and the magnitude is PI cubed over 6
evidently that's around the magnitude of
PI cubed over 6 and so far they've the
vectors have been getting bigger but
it's at this point they start turning
around because basically each time on
the for each new term the numerator gets
an extra pie thrown in but the
denominator now gets an extra 4 thrown
in like going from 6 to 24 you're
multiplying by a 4 and then it's going
to get an extra 5 and then a 6 so the
denominator is going to start growing
much more than the numerator which is
why the vectors shrink and shrink and
start to converge to a point so the I in
there is what's letting these vectors
all turn 90 degrees each time and give
us this very pretty spiral sum and the
claim of Euler's formula is this very
fascinating fact that evidently when the
vectors are rotating according to powers
of I and when their lengths are changing
according to powers of pi divided by n
factorial they all conspire in just the
right way that they land at the point
negative 1 that's interesting still
mysterious but mysterious in a good way
and it's making an even stronger claim
which is that any other angle that we
might put in
it puts us on a unit circle at that
angle now this is especially mysterious
when we consider the fact that as we let
this value just continue increasing it's
not even clear that the function would
be periodic right because as theta
increases more and more of the vectors
become relevant because it takes longer
and longer for the denominator of our
terms to win out and yet they stayed
very nicely constrained on to the unit
circle I think that's interesting
so just to just to do a last little
concept check here I'm gonna ask you one
final question to basically see if
you've been paying attention see if the
the claims-made stand to reason so
getting rid of our powers of I the last
question is a a wind down question of
sorts for the evening which of the
following values is closest to e to the
3 I okay so as usual this is the link
you can go to which of the following
values is closest to e to the 3 I
[Music]
[Music]
you
now as you're answering let me just
remind you that the main takeaway I want
you to have from this lesson is that the
way that you read this is not to think
about a constant e raised to an
imaginary power because that doesn't
really make sense when we're thinking of
powers as repeated exponential repeated
multiplication however what does let's
see it seems like we have some
controversy over the last question we'll
address that in a moment but what you
should think about here is the fact that
e to the X is shorthand for this general
polynomial okay and this general
polynomial it turns out to be very
relevant in things like calculus in a
future lecture I'd like to start talking
about why this idea of X to the N over N
factorial and adding them up why is that
useful why would anyone care why would
it give rotation but if you know that
that's how to read it hopefully this
isn't a nonsense question and it's not
one that just asks you to blindly
believe convention it kind of asks you
to blindly believe a claim about the
fact that this follows a circle but
we'll address that in the next lecture
and I think that's enough time to go
ahead and grade this and the correct
answer is B which around 3800 W nicely
got well done well it done indeed and
it's around negative 0.99 plus 0.1 4i
and so the expectation isn't that you're
a machine who can calculate that in your
head it's instead the idea that if we go
over to our visual where we're plugging
in values of theta and you ask what
happens when you plug in 3 that the
claim of Euler's formula is that we walk
three units around a unit circle knowing
that pi units takes us all the way
around three units should take us so
that the real part is really quite close
to negative one and the imaginary part
is something positive and of the options
you were given those were the only ones
in there now the very last thing that I
would like to emphasize here is that
nothing about this actual expression has
to do with the number E has to do with
the number 2.71828 on and on if we were
to go to the computation taking place if
I plug in something like X of
a complex number whose real part is zero
and whose imaginary part is pi okay
which at first it might look like it's
outputting something other than negative
one but it's saying the real part is
negative one and then some numerical
error because partly because of how we
defined it you know only doing so many
terms and partly because computers can't
can do infinite precision the imaginary
part it might look like it's saying
three point four five but really it's
saying times 10 to the negative 16
that's what that means
so it's basically zero if you wanted to
see this we could maybe import numpy and
do something like round it so I can
round this thing to I don't know eight
decimal places and we see that okay it's
basically negative one so this is the
function that we wrote showing us that e
to the PI is negative one
but what I'd like to emphasize is that
nowhere in that function did we include
the value 2.718 in fact nowhere in the
computer's memory during the execution
of this computation would it encounter
the value 2.718 I would submit to you
that that value is not relevant to the
equation e to the PI I equals negative
one which is kind of funny all right
let's at least find out what the
relationship is because you know I'm not
going to say there's no connection
between e and pi there is one but I
think when you write the very famous
celebrity equation e to the PI I equals
negative one it's it heavily overstates
the connection that there is between
this e and that pi what's really going
on is that we have this function X that
we've defined and that when you plug in
real values okay
when you plug in real numbers for the
reasons we talked about earlier it makes
sense to write x of x in terms of
whatever its value at one happens to be
x but one raised to the X and that we
often call that value X of 1e okay this
is a property of the function another
fact about this is that when we plug in
imaginary numbers the claim of Euler's
formula which I haven't shown why it's
true but the the claim that it's making
is that it's periodic basically that it
walks around a circle and it's periodic
with a period of 2pi
I basically when you increase that input
by 2pi you get back to where you started
and even more specifically that you do
so by walking along a circle so it's
saying that each of these constants is a
child of the function X of X right but
the way that they're related kind of
happens along different dimensions that
I think is the healthy way to understand
this formula now in the next lecture we
are going to be talking about why this
thing walks around in circles and that
misses that necessarily involves a
little bit of calculus so we're going to
get a little bit of calculus into the
mix here but as minimal as I can and
before then I want to leave you with
some homework because if you remember
the core property that related this
strange polynomial with factorials to
the number E was that addition in the
input is the same as multiplication in
the output so before next time I won't
grade this this is just you know to do
to do on your own time in your own way
question number one I want you to show
that when you fully expand X but X times
X of Y and you know you might have
written down for yourself what this
function is it's all those factorial
things so that when you expand that out
each term has the form X to the K times
y to the M divided by K factorial M
factorial for certain whole numbers K
and M and remember zero factorial is
defined to be 1 and question number to
show that when you expand Expo of X plus
y so addition in the input each term is
going to look like 1 over N factorial
times n choose K and times X to the K
times y to the N minus K if you're not
familiar with this term n choose K take
a look at the binomial formula I'm sure
there's plenty of excellent videos on
YouTube about it I'll leave links in the
description as I find them but show that
that's true question 3 compare the two
results
you just found to explain this key
property right the thing that relates
this function to some special constant
and the idea of raising it to powers and
then if you're up for the the bonus
question this is kind of the this is for
all of the extra credit in the world
justify see if you can say will this
result still be true if x and y are
complex numbers and will it still be
true if they're matrices yeah that
actually I think is a very important
exercise to go through to understand
when this is true for what kinds of
inputs because like I said as you get
deeper and deeper into math this X
function remains very relevant and you
start plugging in things that seem
wilder and wilder it's useful it is
genuinely useful and it's important to
know what properties carry over and
which ones don't
no I was talking a little about this
lecture with a friend before hand and I
mentioned the spirit of the lockdown
math series being like high school
classes and you know he looks at me
quizzically and is like is this is that
a high school topic and the honest
answer is I don't know what I can say is
that it is the case that in high school
we came across the formula e to the I
theta I think the first time that I ever
saw it was in you know learning about
complex numbers it was just hot as the
polar representation of complex numbers
to emphasize this idea that when you
multiply two things you you multiply
their magnitudes and you add their
angles but it was just this strange
thing handed from on high the usual way
that we teach a relationship between e
to the X in this polynomial comes from a
piece of calculus called Taylor series
and you start with the function e to the
X always defined in a little bit of a
wishy-washy way depending on the course
that you're taking and then you show
that it's connected to this polynomial
but I think there's no reason we can't
go the other way around
and I actually wish that I had seen this
I wish that I had known from the
beginning that through math especially
through deeper math that this is what
the expression e to the X actually means
so with that I'm going to call an end to
the proper lecture and just take a
couple more questions from the audience
to finish things off maintain the
interactivity that is the spirit of our
of our elections
all right great great we have more
discussion I love this Crispin's proof
is wrong the constant function f of X
equals 0 ah wonderful
ah excellent counter example I think
this is maybe niggling in the back of my
mind it's like I don't think this is
unique
great so you have the case of a function
that is constantly equal to zero and I
think ok whoever was asking a question
earlier that I didn't quite understand I
think this must be what you were getting
at and I didn't I just wasn't reading it
properly but yeah that would be a
function where f of 0 is not necessarily
1 beautiful alright so that question
that I said was wrong and then I said it
wasn't wrong it actually was wrong so
thank you very much Erik moss and to
everyone who can think more clearly
about things than I can why alive on
camera and then another person points
out exactly the same thing I love this
this is just like a real class I'm up
here I get to make mistakes you're down
there you get to correct them and I
think it makes it better for everyone
watching there's a legitimate discussion
to be had what's relevant in the case of
the X function is just that it's not
constantly 0 that it does in fact equal
1 at the input x equals 0 but I love
this discussion and I think I can
imagine no better place to end things
than right there so as always thank you
for joining I hope this helped provide a
little bit of a different perspective
than what you usually see in other
classes on what's a very popular topic
on the Internet at least as math goes
and next time we're going to talk about
why it's true where the circle would
come from I hope to see you then
[Music]
you
[Music]